in germany coal is making a comeback
here in becksback a power station once
marked for closure is being resurrected
it's one of several being brought back
online to help fill the gap left by
dwindling energy supplies from russia
we need energy we need energy in germany
and we need energy
in europe and there is lack of energy
you don't want to imagine if the people
have to live in
in cold housing
to guarantee winter power this
coal-fired plants got to be fully
running by november
horst has come out of retirement to help
how do german people feel about coal
coming back
because we have no other choice we have
to go for other resources you know to
replace the guests
are you worried that you'll run out of
energy or electricity in the winter yes
i'm worried about it
because we have to replace the gas again
and the prices of all energy went up
horrendously
so what else can we do
germany's pledged to totally cut coal by
2038 but the war in ukraine has forced a
temporary resurgence
since june russia has slashed gas
flowing here this week the main pipeline
to europe's being switched off for
maintenance for the second time this
summer
germany is facing rocketing energy
prices and needs to cut its dependence
on russian gas fast renewables and lng
gas will play a role but they take time
nuclear is up for debate but coal fills
the gap now
but coal is the world's dirtiest fossil
fuel
and having lived in the shadow of the
power plant for 15 years ron's angry the
climate's being sacrificed
i think it's stupid
it's a
decision
made by people who are
using the fact that the
population in
germany
has
fear that they won't have
a electricity
which is not true
at this cold store they've seen that
fear in action
with some customers fighting over the
bags
they don't hit each other but the fear
is great and everyone wants the coal
fritioff tells me
germany is confident it can stay warm
this winter
but the solution involves sacrifice and
a green government leaning back on the
planet's most polluting fossil fuel
siobhan robbins sky news germany